Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dansScienceClic, la relativité restreinte.
Imaginons un vaisseau spatial,
ainsi qu'une planète, isolés au fin fond de l'univers.
On va supposer que le vaisseau
est en mouvement parrapport à la planète,
selon une direction fixe, et une vitesse constante.
Une premièrepropriété fondamentale
de l'univers,est que dans cette situation,
il est strictementimpossible
de déterminer si c'est le vaisseau quise déplace,
et la planète qui reste immobile,
ou au contraire si le vaisseau est immobile,
et que c'est la planète qui se déplacedans l'autre sens.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le principe de relativité.
Quel quesoit le point de vue que l'on adopte,
du moment que le mouvement
se faiten ligne droite à vitesse constante,
il est tout autant valide de considérer que c'estsoit le vaisseau,
soit la planète qui se déplace.
Imaginons maintenant un passager duvaisseau,
qui va décider de lancer une balle vers l'avant.
Pour lui, la balle sedéplace vers l'avant, avec une certaine vitesse.
Cette vitesse correspond
tout simplement àl'impulsion qu'il lui a donnée.
Mais si on observe la même situation depuis la planète,
la balle semble se déplacer plus rapidement,
car à sa vitesse d'impulsion s'ajoute
également la vitesse du vaisseau lui-même.
Chose étrange, si l'on essaie maintenant de
faire la même expérience avec de la lumière cette fois-ci,
en utilisant par exempleune lampe torche,
on observe que quelque soit le point de vue adopté,
la vitesse de lalumière est la même.
Qu'on la regarde immobile, ou en se déplaçant.
Qu'on la propulse depuisun point fixe, ou un point en mouvement,
on verra toujours la lumière
se déplacer avecexactement la même vitesse.
On dit que cette vitesse de la lumière est invariante.
La vitessede la lumière est une constante universelle,
fondamentale, à la base de lastructure même de l'univers.
Dans notre quotidien, la vitesse de la lumièreest bien trop élevée
pour qu'on puisse remarquerun quelconque effet de ce principe.
En seulementl'espace d'un clignement d’œil,
un rayon lumineux aura parcouru
l'équivalent de trois allers-retoursParis - New York.
Toutefois, cette propriété subtile de la lumière va entraîner des changementsdrastiques sur notre façon de voir le monde.
En relativité restreinte, une des idées
lesplus fondamentales est que deux événements
peuvent se produire en même temps pour unepersonne,
mais à des moments différents pour quelqu'un d'autre.
Pour comprendre,
imaginons la situation suivante.
Le passager qui se trouve au milieu
duvaisseau se munit de deux lampes torches,
une qu'il va orienter vers l'arrière,et l'autre vers l'avant.
Son rôle va être d'allumer les deux
lampes torchesexactement en même temps.
Il va ensuite regarder à quel moment arrivent
les deuxrayons lumineux aux extrémités du vaisseau.
Il commence par allumer
les deux lampes torchesau même moment.
Étant donné que selon son point de vue le vaisseau reste immobile,
lesrayons lumineux vont
se propager de lamême façon des deux côtés.
Ils vont ainsiatteindre les deux
extrémités du vaisseauau même moment.
Pour le passager, lesdeux événements sont donc simultanés,
les rayons lumineux ont atteint les deux
extrémités du vaisseau en même temps.
Mais regardons maintenant cette même situation,
telle qu'elle est perçue par un observateur àla surface de la planète.
On a vu précédemment
que la vitesse de la lumière est invariante.
Par conséquent,
au moment où les deux lampes torchess'allument,
leur lumière va se propager à la même vitesse des deux côtés.
Mais pendant ce temps,
le vaisseau se déplace vers l'avant.
Ainsi, le rayon lumineux qui est envoyé vers la gauche
va atteindre l'arrière du vaisseau
avant que le rayon lumineux de droite n'atteigne l'avant.
Selonce point de vue,
les deux événements ne sont donc plus simultanés,
les rayons lumineux n'atteignent
pas les extrémités du vaisseau au même moment.
Pour expliquer ce paradoxe, il va nous falloir
bouleverser notre compréhension intuitive de ce qu'est le temps.
Dans la situation précédente, si le rayon lumineuxde gauche
atteint le bord du vaisseau avant lerayon lumineux de droite,
c'est en réalité parceque l'arrière
du vaisseau est légèrement dans lefutur
par rapport à l'avant du vaisseau
quiest légèrement dans le passé.
Grossièrement, lorsqu'il est
par exemple midi au milieudu vaisseau,
il est déjà 13h à l'arrière du vaisseau,
mais il n'est encore que 11hà l'avant du vaisseau.
Depuis le passager, à l'intérieur,
les horloges sont pourtantparfaitement synchronisées.
Pour lui, il est tout aussi bien midi à l'avant qu'àl'arrière du vaisseau.
C'est le fait de l'observer depuis un point en mouvement
qui vadésynchroniser l'arrière et l'avant du vaisseau.
De manière plus générale,
lorsqu'un objet sedéplace à très grande vitesse par rapport à nous,
on observe que l'avant de l'objet
est en retarddans le temps par rapport à l'arrière.
Si l'on plaçait par exemple
deux personnes dumême âge aux extrémités du vaisseau,
on observerait depuis la planète que la personne
à l'avant du vaisseau est légèrement plus jeune,
et la personne à l'arrière légèrement plus âgée.
Une conséquence directe de ce phénomène,
est cequ'on appelle la contraction des longueurs.
Comme on l'a vu précédemment,
lorsqu'il est observédepuis la planète,
l'arrière du vaisseau est légèrement
dans le futur par rapport à l'avant.
Mais comme le vaisseau se déplace au cours du temps,
si l'arrière du vaisseau est dans le futur,
il est également légèrement
en avance par rapport à son mouvement.
De même, l'avant est légèrement
en retrait par rapport au mouvement du vaisseau.
La longueur globale du vaisseau se voit donc
contractée, dans le sens de sa vitesse.
A des vitesses ordinaires,
cette contraction estminime, quasiment indétectable.
Par exemple, une voiture se déplaçant à 130 km par heure
ne sera contractée que d'environ la largeur d'un noyau d'atome.
Mais plus on se rapprochede la vitesse de la lumière,
plus ce phénomène de contraction devient important.
Si notrevaisseau pouvait
se déplacer à 85% de la vitesse de la lumière,
sa longueur serait contractée demoitié.
Et à 99,5% de la vitesse de la lumière, sa longueur
observée ne serait plusqu'un dixième de sa longueur originale.
Dans cette situation, vu depuis la
planète, le vaisseau nous semble terriblement contracté.
Mais du point devue du passager qui se trouve à l'intérieur,
ce n'est pas le vaisseau quiest contracté, mais la planète,
car selon son point de vue,
c'est laplanète qui se déplace et non le vaisseau.
Enfin, une troisième conséquence
directe del'invariance de la vitesse de la lumière
est ce qu'on appelle la dilatation des durées.
Pourcomprendre, imaginons l'expérience suivante.
Le passager à l'intérieur du vaisseau
se munit à nouveau d'une lampe torche,
qu'il va cette fois-ci diriger vers le haut.
A uninstant donné, il va allumer la lampe torche,
et observer le temps que met le rayon
lumineux pour atteindre le plafond du vaisseau.
Encore une fois,le problème va changer
si l'on décide d'observer la même situation mais depuis la planète.
Pour l'observateur qui se trouve sur la planète,
levaisseau, et le passager qu'il contient, sont enmouvement.
Par conséquent, le faisceau lumineuxva
non seulement devoir parcourir la hauteurjusqu'au plafond,
mais il va également devoir sedéplacer vers
la droite, en suivant le mouvement du vaisseau.
D'après ce point de vue, le rayonlumineux
doit donc parcourir une distance plus grande
Et par conséquent, tout comme il faut plus
de temps pour traverser une route en diagonale,
que dans le sens de la largeur,
il va falloir à lalumière
plus de temps pour atteindre le plafond du vaisseau.
Pour cet observateur qui regarde lasituation depuis la planète,
le rayon lumineux a donc mis
davantage de temps pour atteindre lehaut du vaisseau.
En général, cet observateur va voir
l'intérieur du vaisseau évoluer au ralenti.
Si le passager du vaisseau décidait
par exemple de lui montrer une horloge,
on observerait depuisla planète
que cette horloge s'écoule au ralenti.
Plus généralement, lorsqu'un objet
se déplacetrès rapidement par rapport à nous,
on verra son arrière et son avant
désynchronisés, sa longueurcontractée,
et on le verra évoluer au ralenti.
Pour résumer tous ces phénomènes,
on vas'intéresser au cas concret des muons.
Dans la haute atmosphère,
il arrive régulièrement quepénètrent des particules cosmiques.
Ces particules cosmiques,
très énergétiques, vont progressivementse désintégrer,
jusqu'à engendrer des particules
élémentaires qu'on appelle des muons.
Dans unesituation normale,
ces muons ont une durée de vie extrêmement courte.
Ils disparaissent au bout dequelques microsecondes seulement.
Mais pourtant, lorsqu'on essaie
de les détecter depuis lasurface de la Terre,
on se rend compte qu'un grand nombre de ces muons
parvient tout de mêmeà atteindre le sol.
Cette situation à première vue paradoxale,
va pouvoir s'expliquer grâce
auxphénomènes qu'on a vus précédemment.
En effet, les muons qui chutent vers le sol
peuventatteindre des vitesses vertigineuses,
près de 99,5% de la vitesse dela lumière.
On va donc devoir s'intéresser
aux phénomènes de contractiondes longueurs,
et de dilatation des durées.
D'une part,
commençons par nous placer du pointde vue d’un muon.
Pour le muon c'est la Terre, et en particulier l'atmosphère,
quise déplacent très rapidement dans sa direction.
Par le phénomènede contraction des longueurs,
le muon va donc voir une atmosphère contractée,
beaucoup plus fine, et par conséquent
il va pouvoir la traverser entièrement
avantd'avoir eu le temps de disparaître.
D'autre part,
si l'on se place du pointde vue d'un observateur sur Terre,
ce sont les muons qui se déplacentavec une très grande vitesse.
Par le phénomène de dilatation des durées,
onva donc voir les muons évoluer au ralenti,
et par conséquent,
leur durée de vie va noussembler très allongée.
Encore une fois les muons vont avoir le temps d'atteindre lesol,
bien avant de ne s'être désintégrés.
Pour conclure,
le simple fait que la vitessede la lumière soit invariante
entraîne de très lourdes
conséquences sur notre façonde voir le monde.
Lorsqu'un objet se déplace par rapport à nous,
en lignedroite, avec une très grande vitesse,
on le voit évoluer au ralenti, tandis qu'il
nous semble contracté dans le sens du mouvement.
Cette façon de comprendre larelativité du temps et de l'espace,
en fonction du mouvement des objets,
est ce qu'on appelle la relativité restreinte.
Elle nous enseigne que le tempset l'espace
ne sont pas des notions absolues,
que deux observateurs vont
potentiellement lespercevoir de façon différente.
Elle entraîne également un grand nombre d'autres conséquences,
comme le fait qu'il soit absolument
impossible de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière,
car neserait-ce que pour atteindre cette vitesse,
il faudrait disposer d’une quantité infinie d'énergie.
Mais cette forme de relativité estappelée « restreinte »,
car elle nes'applique que dans des cas très simples,
pourdes mouvements qui ne se font
qu'en ligne droite,et à vitesse constante.
Elle n'est pas enmesure de décrire d'autres types de mouvement,
par exemple des changements de direction,
des accélérations, des ralentissements,
ou encore des rotations.
Pour ce faire, il vaêtre nécessaire
de s'intéresser à une théorie beaucoup plus complète,
qui permet entre autresd'expliquer l'attraction gravitationnelle
à partir d'une géométrie déformée de l'espace et du temps,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la relativité générale.